hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich bin mit spd sec kann man
schon fast sagen oder muss man schlagen
ja ja ja ja ja heute habe ich war für
euch und farbe nicht erstens weil ein
video gestolpert archiv-video will make
you hate justin bieber also auf deutsch
nach diesem video wirst du justin bieber
haften und ich persönlich bin dem typen
eigentlich gar nicht negativ gegenüber
eingestellt also ich finde das gut
gemacht
seine musik wird zwar bis hin zu häufig
gespielt aber selbst die musik ist
eigentlich mittlerweile voll cool
insgesamt ist das einfacher und vor
allem als persönlichkeit mega
interessanter typ jetzt bin ich wirklich
gespannt was dieses video mit uns macht
ob wir sagen okay verstehen wir was er
in diesem videos machen die ihr handeln
oder ist ein facharzt und wir starten
war yvonne held
[Musik]
leider gibt es schon hart aber
andererseits wird davor warten will und
das ist garantiert auch noch wird man
muss verhalten der hyper fucking jung ja
ja ja das auch wenn immer alles auf tief
gewesen wäre was ich schon so vor
laufender kamera in der schweiz führten
kate möchte braucht also ich mache schon
auch immer job und ich meine ja
wahrscheinlich nicht gewollt dass an die
öffentlichkeit ging und irgendwie mal
dachte sich justin bieber das
veröffentlichen besser also das kann man
noch verstehen aber es ist schon ein
bisschen kleiner schock nevermann dass
die gipfeltreffen ergebnis gemeinsam
[Musik]
die leute wild auf die hülle werten das
verfängt nicht
neues level wir können kaum welche
richtungen
das waren die leute die wir eher der
reihe stehen zahlen beim ersten 500 euro
[Gelächter]
das ist aber irgendwie ist aber auch
witzig aber glocken läuten vorstellung
der tief wurde sein ganzes leben lang
ist oft und paparazzi und fans also bei
den überresten ja also bisher ich muss
sagen ich hab ein bisschen weil ich
meine dadurch ist er sicher so ein
bisschen menschlicher besten
menschlichen für ein bisschen verarscht
aber ist okay also bisher die nummer
haben gespuckt das baugebiet in die
menge zu werfen ja nicht so die menge zu
werden sondern so hier
hier darf das war locker wurde das café
eingerahmt locker flockig gab auch also
ohne spaß wahrscheinlich hat irgendwie
so ne art sport wenn das genommen
megastar
fiktion aber hilft kann man übertrieben
gut verstehen bei den justin bieber
anfängt irgendwo fotos zu machen hört
niemals auf den rest wird immer jemand
ohne foto aufgehen und die sache ist
selbst wenn keine ahnung wirkung die in
der stadt unterwegs sind und dann sehen
leute audi machen fotos entstehen die
sich sicherheitshalber auch meine
machen.foto mit justin bieber ist es
wahrscheinlich komplett craven das kann
ich ein bisschen verstehen
unter berichtigen
man kann beide seiten verstehen
jeder kommt auch verstehen er absolut
cool es war schon hart wie es gesagt hat
erkennt bei moskau ich hasse ihn noch
nicht
aktion dabei also auch immer nun also
wahrscheinlich beim hotel
ich glaube nur wenn das die schlimmsten
momente sind sein jeder mensch hat
richtig schlimm
moment ich zum beispiel manchmal holen
dafür richtig krank wir machen einfach
aber auch wir sind menschen die fans
[Musik]
also wenn er wenn der comedian und ihn
verraten will ok aber wenn er kein wort
über die macht würde minimiert ist von
der kleinen rucksack ist daher sehr gut
der hat auch voll geschrieben
kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass er das
auch nicht
[Musik]
das video
eine frage wieso fragt man den 16
jährigen sänger was er von
schwangerschaft ist doch eine frage die
alle irgendwie keine ahnung hat
ich habe nach wie vor nicht also ich
muss sagen dass meine schlimmsten
momente sind können wir uns ja beim
nächsten mal eine komplette momente
weinberg hat dafür dass mit den besten
moment mit einzelnen schreibt das in die
kommentare ich hoffe das video hat euch
gefallen finde ich persönlich
interessant also fangen wir auch mal
keine ahnung schreibt mir die kommentare
wir so etwas gemacht oder gesagt was für
eine art wochen bis zum nächsten mal
ihr könnt übrigens gerne ein altes video
anschauen hier unten abonnieren das
würde mich sehr freuen macht's gut bis
dahin schafft